[Musique]
dans les salles aussi décès de cette
semaine le très joli deuxième film
deuxième jeu précise de nicolas bedos
après le très réussi et remarquable
monsieur le label made que vous avez
certainement vu avec nicolas bedos et
doria tillier dans cette fois ci un
casting exceptionnel
daniel auteuil qui fort heureusement est
très bien employé dans ce film mais
c'est vrai qu'auteuil un petit peu de
mal à trouver des rôles à sa démesure
ouais sa démesure c'est quand même un
très grand acteur il faut pas oublier
bien sûr la très grande famille ardent
il ya aussi pierre arditi public
caennais et dorian thiviers bien sûr la
muse la femme
l'amoureuse nicolas bedos voit donc
c'est un film une comédie dramatique
tendre et féroce à la fois je vais pas
vous raconter l'histoire par le menu
mais le scénario est très original on
propose à daniel auteuil de revivre ou
de plus belle journée de sa venue
grâce à une société qui a monté
guillaume canet vous en dit pas plus
vous venez de découvrir dans notre salle
il est encore à l'affiché cette semaine
au ciné cette un très joli film pour
cette fin d'année
[Musique]